thank you for everyone for coming out
tonight seems like everybody brought
their little piece of paper for their
speech so I hope I won't forget what I'm
gonna say so first I want to say
congratulations to everyone every winner
here the finalists and the
semi-finalists of this year's do an
Academy Award
you guys are so amazingly creative and
so amazingly inspiring so I'm just so
honored to be among you guys and
learning so much from you thank you so
ten years ago when I first had my first
step on this soil I got very
disappointed because I didn't see too
many skycrapers like I have seen in
second city so I thought this is another
real United States but ten years later I
am standing here feeling excited and
surreal but most importantly inspired
being the first-generation immigrant in
this country is hard but being a
filmmaker is even harder so my journey
of becoming a filmmaker has been
challenging but rather saying full and
grateful so I'm gonna really use this
time to thank a lot of people so I will
try my best to make it short so first I
want to thank my team right here my
wonderful crew my producers Stephanie
Stephanie Hermia
my editors Sharon and Adam who's not
here and my DP Patrick and my two
wonderful soundy and mixer Audrey and
davia and also one and the only composer
Andy
they have been so supportive of me when
I even lost facing myself and I couldn't
have asked a better team than them and
also I want to thank all my faculty
support also here today Cade Amanda
Lisa Richard you guys not only the
amazing documentary filmmakers but they
have been the wonderful teacher who
spent hours in the lab with me literally
making the film with us so I think
that's the best example of being teacher
so thank you guys and also I wanted to
thank the two women in my film
Nicole Evans and her husband I mean her
husband's not a female but there'll be a
lovely couple in the movie and they have
been so inspiring and also Karin Crispo
who's not here today she's actually
under going through some surgical
operation but because of these women
they have made me a better human being
they have taught me the definition of
strength persistence and love so thank
you guys
and I would really make it short so and
also I just have to thank my family
first my parents I have to say you know
they they told me everything you know to
be a daughter and you know how I didn't
disappoint them you know ten years ago
they left everything in China and came
here for my education for my future
so mom and dad I love you thank you so
much and of course my my husband and who
flew in this morning three years ago in
the same theatre that was the first time
we were here and we're not dating yet
you know he was just having a crush on
me but we were here and I saw the winner
of that year I was like you know can I
be one of them one day he's like yeah
you're gonna make it and now I'm here so
thank you and thank you for being my
love as well I think he might friends
who have given you their cultures and
best literally in the past few months
I've been crashing their couches and
beds and for free so thank you guys and
lastly I want to thank the Academy when
I was a little girl in China I could
never imagine I was saying those exact
words today but I am saying it right now
and say thank you to the Academy thank
you actors Thank You Sean thank you
Randy the you know everyone who have
made this event so amazingly for us and
lastly I just want to say to all the
filmmakers out who I have spend this
past week with the you know with they
have inspired me so much not only making
me a better person but also a better
storyteller so thank you guys all for
coming out supporting us thank you